okay let's talk about this
[Applause]
[Music]
so this is something that I haven't
really done directly before I've talked
about Doctor Who Doctor Who music before
I even did a top-10 Marigold tracks
which I actually did before the official
release of series 9 and 10 which means
that there are now tracks out there that
it would have been on that list if I'd
had them at the time but in any case
it's been a while since I talked about
it and I really kind of wish I'd tackled
this sooner the reason I'm talking about
this now is I just kind of dragged my
feet with getting my hands on the
soundtrack to Doctor Who series 11 I
have most of the other soundtracks not
all of them there's a couple of the
later Smith ones that I don't have not
because they're not good but because
it's mostly remixes from the earlier
stuff and I don't feel like shelling out
the cash for it but normally by and
large I kind of jump on these things
pretty quickly but I didn't with series
11 and it's not because I remember the
music being bad I just don't really
remember the music like at all there's
plenty I remember from series 11 for
good and ill but the music always just
kind of flew under the radar it never
left much of an impression so I wasn't
really chomping at the bit to get my
hands on and actually listen to the
thing front to back now that I've done
that yet it's actually pretty good but I
also know why I didn't remember it that
well it is a decidedly different
approach to doing music for a show like
Doctor Who than had been done previously
under Murray gold the new composer whose
name I am now gonna look up because and
I'll probably still say it wrong
siga and a canola apologies that this
new sound is it's very ambient and it's
very situational and it's much more
intended as an hour undercurrent Murray
gold he had he kind of came from the
John Williams School of of soundtracks
you know big theme he's bold setting you
know bold brass sections you know really
identifiable care
themes that recur and get reused as
these characters show up again and as
their arcs clothes and things like that
this approach now in series 11 I
apologize I'm not gonna keep saying the
composer's name just because I'm afraid
we're gonna butcher it or forget how it
is and I don't want to have to look at
my phone every time but I the approach
here is much more mood music it's much
more undercurrent it is not about theme
for this character theme for this
monster and in fact pretty much all of
the tracks are labeled either under a
line of dialogue that occurred in a
scene or like the setting of a scene
pretty much nobody has a theme because
like every version of the in new who at
least every version of the doctor has
had something that is unique to them in
terms of the thing while nine kind of
had to share his with 10 but then 10 got
things like the doctor forever that was
used just for him and 11 had I and the
doctor and 12 had a good man and you had
these unique themes for them and then
most of the companions had unique themes
as well Rose had a different sounds of
Martha a different sounds of Donna and
so on and so on so to have not have
these immediately identifiable themes is
a very different approach and ultimately
a less memorable one but again that's
not actually a flaw in and of itself
it's just a difference in approach it's
basically the difference between drawing
attention to the music and having the
music play a supporting role which is
what it does now but when I actually
listen to the music in isolation
I was surprised at how solid it is but
it really does gigas I tried to sit down
and like focus on it but you know I have
a beedi I was doing other stuff and it
would just fade into the background and
I would like I would miss when tracks
would turn over and it's not because
they bleed one into the other is because
they don't have the hard starts and hard
cut offs that a Marigold track does so
even like enlist I've listened to the
thing like three times all the way
through and how and I have a hard time
remembering specific
make tracks not because I not because
they left no impression whatsoever but
because the whole thing is just a much
more Zen experience and which as a
general vibe is an interesting
difference in terms of approach and if
they work on a retain Maori gold I think
ultimately was probably a pretty good
call because if you bring in somebody
that has Murray Gold's approach then all
you can do is say who you know who wore
it better but you bring in a composer
with a decidedly different approach and
yes some people will still have their
preference for one of the other but it
also becomes comparing apples to oranges
you can go well yeah okay I'd like this
one or this one better but they're not
trying to be the same thing so maybe we
don't have to make them butt heads and
argue who did it best so and I think
that's that's a good thing yeah it's
kind of a it's kind of a healthy thing
to have it be that way and I it also is
solid enough that it doesn't feel like a
downgrade in terms of the music it
doesn't feel like we are getting lesser
compositions it just feels like we're
getting less showy compositions and like
is it just not drawing as much attention
to themselves as Murray Gold's tracks
would and there's a few other
interesting things that they do as I
said there aren't there isn't really
much in the way of recurrent themes that
get carried over episode to episode
there are recurrent themes within an
episode or within a couple of episodes
so like related to the doctor in both
the woman who fell to earth and in the
ghost monument there's a really
wonderful kind of almost mournful violin
piece that I found myself like listening
for and later tracks and not hearing
because that oh is that the doctors
theme and is like doesn't really come up
all that much later on so I guess not or
like for Rosa
it had an for lack of a better term an
oddly patriotic sound to it there was
sort of this solo horn that actually
what it really reminded me of was the
music from a few good men
like I don't not that anybody like
remembers the music from a few good men
but you know I was in it as a play so I
knew the movie you know pretty pretty
well not that I studied the movie to
play the part I actually stopped
watching movie to play the part how does
this become about me being in community
theater anyways it but it had that sort
of like I don't know it just the the
that approach made me think slightly
proud military slightly patriotic theme
but that again that didn't recur and a
bunch of other music from other episodes
it was confined to Rosa um or like Andy
here was one where actually the one time
the music did jump out of me but that
was because it didn't work but was not
necessarily the music well it was
somebody's fault I don't know it was the
composer's that's the music for the
Saranga conundrum so there is a track on
the on the soundtrack album called
Saranga which is actually a pretty good
track it's one of the more memorable
ones overall I would think but the thing
is it didn't work in the episode because
the vibe of the music was completely at
odds with the look of the quote-unquote
monster ie
the music and it wasn't just the music
it was the way it was lit and it was the
way the characters were acting was all
very like okuu serious but like it it
looked like stitch you know from a
Disney cartoon so that was a case where
the music didn't work but it was because
there it was not properly integrated and
it contrasted too harshly with another
element that was going on and again I'm
not sure that was the composer's fault
given actually how much in contrast with
the way the thing was shot the way they
the actors were I really have to wonder
how much redesign did that thing go
through between when it was conceived
and when the special effects are
actually rendered a cuz I have a
suspicion it went through a redesign and
looked quite different from what people
thought they were gonna be dealing with
but that's that's getting into into a
tangent but it's
it's a good soundtrack I do enjoy it
it's hard for me to recommend as a thing
necessarily to buy because like I said
it it depends on what you want if you
like a more ambient soundtrack a more
mood kind of music it'll do you quite
well for that if you love Doctor Who
music as in Murray gold music it's
harder to say what I would say is if you
if you go on something like Spotify you
can stream the album if you if you've
got like the premium version of Spotify
it's right on there give it a listen and
I think a fair number of people are
probably gonna come over the oppression
I had which is wow this is a lot better
than I had kind of assumed it was I was
gonna say better than I remember a being
but the thing was I didn't really
remember it being anything but listen to
it in isolation I now kind of feel like
it's one of the stronger elements of
series 11 one of the least showy
elements but there's nothing wrong with
music playing a supporting role and just
setting the mood as opposed to really
dictating what's going on or announcing
a character not that that's wrong either
but it's a totally solid way to do it
and if you're gonna take that approach
this music does it really well so if you
again it's hard for me to recommend like
actually paying full price for the album
but if you have access to it I would
recommend giving you to listen I think a
lot more people will find something to
like in it than maybe they thought so
that's the series 11 soundtrack I just I
heard it I finally and I want to talk
about it
have you heard it what did you think
about it do you agree with my assessment
do you think I'm completely off-base do
you actually have a favorite track um oh
everything I say the the current
composition for the main theme during
the opening credits do really like that
like a lot I really like that version of
the the main opening credit themes but
in any case whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
talk about those buttons and links you
can like and subscribe and see more
stuff and help me in the algorithm in
this or support me on patreon or share
this with friends or their socials and
there's merch and that like whole bunch
of stuff
pama stuff click on things or don't it's
okay because at the end of the day
you're the council
I'm just running the meetings so until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]